this comes up against an assumption that
i think we make that man someone
subscribed that's a subscriber for life
that person's gonna be with me forever
they subscribe to my youtube channel
we're probably gonna be closer than me
and my spouse my gosh they're gonna care
and hang on every single word that i
ever say hey welcome back to the think
media podcast the number one podcast to
help you grow your youtube channel and
then turn that youtube channel into a
high impact and a high profit online
business man i am so excited for today's
episode because we're answering your
questions did you know that on the
community tab on youtube we post on
there asking you what topics you would
like us to cover and today's topic
actually comes from artistically me and
mr winner and you're talking all about
and asking questions about how do you
revive your subscribers do you have a
dead channel do you have dead
subscribers are you wanting to reach
your active subscribers well in today's
episode we're gonna dive into all of
that hey i have a question for you also
do you follow us on instagram did you
know we have an official think media
instagram it's actually at official
think media you can take a screenshot
right now and tag us and let us know
what your aha moment is from today's
episode alright well let's not keep you
waiting any longer and let's get into
today's topic
[Music]
i'm fired up about this episode because
i feel like defining these terms is
really important and so in a second i'll
share five tips on how to reach kind of
your active subscribers or activate
dormant subscribers but let's start with
dead subscribers and the honest truth is
if your subscribers are dead it's
actually impossible to reach them
because there's really three scenarios
there right number one they've lost
interest like they just are subscribed
but they're just not paying attention
anymore that's probably a dead
subscriber number two they lost their
login and they are a subscriber but
they're not even in the youtube app
anymore with that account so they're a
number on your account but they're not
doing anything and the third scenario
if we're honest is they literally died
it's kind of crazy but over time you
think about like a subscriber that may
have actually passed away it's kind of a
crazy thought but again regardless it's
technically impossible to reach dead
subscribers but the
other way to look at this is well maybe
they're not dead
maybe they're dormant right just because
they subbed
it just doesn't mean that they're
actually easy to reach one of the things
we have to realize in 2021 and 2022 and
2023
is that just because someone clicks
subscribe does not in any way guarantee
that your content is going to reach them
in fact here at think media we've
discovered that consumption
is greater than subscription
but actually people vote with their
minutes more than they vote with their
sub button i don't know about you maybe
you've subscribed to a channel you
scroll through your subscription feed
but if you're not clicking on their
videos you're not actually really voting
with your time which is the biggest
metric minutes matter most so actually
when you consume someone's content it's
actually more powerful than a
subscription in fact a lot of people
will
maybe be an active passionate fan viewer
of yours and they may never subscribe
why is this it's because they're
watching so many of your videos your
videos are just showing up on their
homepage being suggested to you you
never click the subscribe button but
that person feels like they're just
having your videos pushed to them
and so it's interesting that subscribers
we really think are in a way less
valuable than they once were because
consumption
is greater
than subscription
and there's really a bunch of different
categories like i think we have to we'll
go into some tips here but i think about
answering this question you have to say
okay when it comes to my sub count and
let us know how many subs do you have
are you just starting do you have a
thousand do you have 10 000 at think
media we're on our way to 1.8 million
but here's the other thing is that's
taken 10 years to
grow the channel that large and out of
those one paint uh 1.8 million here's
some different categories of where our
subscribers fall into number one they're
dead right they're completely inactive
number two they're dormant we would love
to find a way to reactivate them number
three they're casual like they're kind
of a think media fan but they're on the
fringes and this would be true for your
channel as well number four they're
committed like they're committed
subscribers they're die hard they want
to watch almost every video you uh post
and number five they're viewers that
don't know how to sub right like there's
people like my parents don't know how to
subscribe to channels but they told me
recently that they now have favorite
youtubers which is this singing married
couple that sings classic songs in a car
together when their kids are sleeping in
different outfits like my parents are
into youtube but they're not like
subscribing they didn't create an
account they're viewers that don't know
how to subscribe but they love your
content so ultimately let's get into
some practical tactics here how do you
actually reach your active subscribers
or the people that clicked the
subscription button number one
ask yourself
why did they subscribe in the first
place
why did they subscribe
in the first place
your goal would be to recover the topics
that they clicked on to subscribe in the
first place and this first point is
crucial and this can kill a lot of
channels
one of the things you can do if you've
been on youtube for a while is go into
your analytics
look at your real-time views that's
views that have happened in the last 60
minutes and in the last two days you
might see that you've got a video or two
or three that just keeps getting views
maybe it gets views literally every hour
but what happens to a lot of people that
we coach and a lot of people that we
encourage here at think media is we
sometimes go to their youtube channel
maybe today they're making content
that's all about jeeps and they're
talking about jeep tires and how to
you know
deck out your jeep engine and how to
off-road and all this kind of stuff but
a couple years ago they made a video
about like firearms or something and
there's like this video about like how
to clean your shotgun and that one video
is getting all kinds of subscribers it's
driving all the views it's driving all
the subscribers but the problem is
the people who are clicking subscribe
what kind of content would they want
they would want more more maybe firearm
or hunting content and they don't care
about your jeep content so you got to
ask yourself why did the subscribers
subscribe in the first place and maybe
one of the reasons why you're not
reaching them is because your videos
aren't even really being shown or
distributed to them because you are not
uploading videos that they originally
subscribe for
we say this a lot never upload a video
your subscribers
didn't subscribe for
that's actually in our opinion a youtube
law a youtube rule now rules are maybe
at some times made to be broken but you
need to know the rules like we cert we
understand that if we upload an adobe
premiere tutorial which is video editing
software on think media
that the people who subscribe for the
final cut tutorials are probably not
going to switch software so they're not
going to want to click on that video so
we understand that usually when we go
really niche like that and teach on a
specific software the video doesn't do
great in terms of click-through rate and
average view duration or really
click-through rate because that's not
relevant for everybody however our
strategy is in the long term that video
will find its way to the people who are
interested in in it but nevertheless we
recognize that ah man we're not reaching
our active subscribers or we're not you
know
oh my gosh i have so many subscribers
but they're not seeing this video is
that video what they subscribe for in
the first place and can you recover the
topics that your current subscribers
want to watch the most number two try to
increase your click-through rate and
your average view duration
this is how youtube works
once you have some subscribers it's
actually a good thing but it can be
dangerous
because what youtube does is it says
okay these a thousand people have
subscribed to your channel they want to
watch your content they've at least
raised their hand to have a chance of
seeing your content first so what you
the youtube algorithm will do is you
upload a new video and it will show it
to some of your subscribers it might
test that video on their home page
because everyone's homepage is different
right when you log into youtube on your
phone or your desktop it might test the
video there
so it shows that video to a portion of
your subscribers
next question
if none of your subscribers click on it
not only will youtube not show it to
more of your subscribers but it probably
won't reach beyond
a small pu
pool of viewers
secondly maybe everybody clicks on it so
it has a high click click-through rate
like wow
your subscribers want to see this so
people who are like your subscribers and
youtube studies that will also be shown
that video but then ultimately people
drop off they're like ah this is what i
thought it was it was click bait and so
that's the view duration the minutes the
watch time that's not very good either
so the video gets killed once it gets
launched the flip side
you upload a new video
and
people your subscribers are super pumped
they click on it like crazy
people who are like your subscribers
again youtube studying everybody they
start being shown the video they're
interested too that thumbnail that title
gets their gets their interest they
click on it like crazy and the content
is so engaging and it holds people's
attention for 50 60 70 all the way to
the end of the video and they keep
showing it to new people and it keeps
getting viewed and clicked on
well then that is how that video gets
spread
not just to your subscribers
but also to
people who are unsubscribed or not
subscribed to your channel and they may
become subscribers or they just may
consume that one video and that's kind
of the recipe for a viral video and it
comes back down to those two metrics of
click-through rate and average view
duration
biggest way to do that is your title
topic and your thumbnails and we've
covered that in other episodes so make
sure you're definitely subscribed to the
podcast make sure you're subscribed to
the think media main channel and we have
other trainings on that but
click-through rate and average view
duration are going to be the levers that
are going to help you reach your current
subscriber base number three encourage
viewers to turn on notifications
one of the ways to
reach your subscribers is even the
reason there is notifications is as
youtube gets more crowded and there are
more channels and there are more
opportunities and more things for people
to watch
notifications becomes that extra switch
you know 12 years ago on youtube
just a subscription maybe met you were
going to reach a large percentage of
your subscribers well every year on
social it gets a little more crowded and
organic reach typically goes down
youtube's a little bit different because
when you really have a video pop off
with click through rate and average view
duration it you can break through even
if you're a brand new creator it's a
very special platform but typically for
that day-to-day content that day-to-day
grind where you're putting out videos
and just trying to reach your core
audience it's harder if they're just
subscribed
so if you could say hey turn on you know
ring the bell turn on notifications
that's an extra level of distribution to
your most passionate
fans that may want to make sure they
don't miss your content and one thing to
consider is actually educating your
audience about what notifications are
how do they even work you know if people
don't have push notifications on their
phone well they're not going to see that
if they don't check their email they're
not going to see that a lot of times
notifications are in-app notifications
and we won't go into it here but if
you're already like i don't even know
how notifications work then your
audience probably definitely doesn't
know how notifications work and so think
about slowing down a little bit and
trying to educate your core audience to
say hey if you really want to make sure
you don't miss any of our content turn
on notifications which i want to
encourage you if you're on youtube it
might be a good time to ring the bell on
the think media podcast channel and turn
on notifications so that you don't miss
any of our podcasts or the youtube made
simple show with heather or the coffee
with kennel live show that i do we're
here to serve you help you win on
youtube and so if you don't want to miss
anything
ring the bell
number four
find ways to communicate with core
viewers off
of youtube
you know one of the best things you
could do is of course grow on youtube
but never depend
on youtube that's why i think media we
have an email list it's another way to
communicate with you to get you
information to give you a summary every
week of the videos that have come out
across our channels so all in one place
you can maybe pick out a video you
missed on a topic you're interested in
this is why we are building a text
message list this is why we do at the
stage we're at now diversifying the
social media
this is why we want to be able to
again
find other ways to communicate with
you because we realize we cannot control
the youtube algorithm what i would
encourage you is don't try to grow
everywhere all at once don't try to grow
a text message list a messenger bot list
which is like facebook messenger bots or
instagram message
uh you know an email list like all these
different things it could be a
distraction and there's a lot of kind of
a technical side and a maintenance side
to it but keep in mind that as think
media continues to evolve and as we've
hired team we have said of course we
want to focus on youtube subscriptions
but we gotta diversify we cannot we
can't control any of the platforms so we
want to have those communication
channels diversified
and if you would call your subscribers
active
that's for them to decide how active do
they want to be how much information do
they really want if they really don't
want to miss anything give people
opportunities to maybe join your text
message list we use a service called
community to join your email list we are
probably switching recently but we just
use kajabi which hosts our online
courses we just use their email
management software it's called a crm is
another term for it customer
relationships manager there's other
terms for it and so find one of those as
a step maybe that's not your next step
building your youtube business today but
think about that in your journey of
finding ways to keep up communications
with your community and then number five
lastly
reach new subscribers you know what do i
do about my dead subscribers what do i
do about how do i reach my active
subscribers another thing to focus on is
reaching new subscribers
you know what's interesting is in
business there's something called
customer attrition
customer attrition is the loss of
customers by a business
most customers of any given business
will not remain active customers
indefinitely this comes up against an
assumption that i think we make that man
someone subscribed that's a subscriber
for life that person's gonna be with me
forever they subscribe to my youtube
channel we're probably gonna be closer
than me and my spouse my gosh they're
gonna care and hang on every single word
that i ever say that person clicks
subscribed i can depend on them to buy
my book watch my videos attend my live
streams i wouldn't be surprised if
they're rearranging their entire life
around me like that that subscriber
they're probably coming to my son's
birthday party like that and and of
course that sounds extreme but sometimes
that's the assumption we have
like people are a lot more casual than
we think like think about your behavior
you click subscribe you didn't like
enter into a covenantal relationship
with that channel like you're like i
don't know maybe i want to watch some of
their videos in the future
and so i think we need to be aware
as youtube entrepreneurs
that customer attrition will happen
viewer attrition will happen and that
people are going to go through seasons
of life and i think that also can really
help you with maybe your identity or
your feeling like if you're doing
something wrong sure there's things for
you to improve but some things are
completely out of your control they just
lost interest it wasn't anything you did
they decided they didn't want to be into
jeeps anymore they sold the jeep they're
not going to be into jeeps anymore and
you know what they might have done they
didn't click unsubscribe they keep
swiping past and they're like ah so my
jeep miss it but i don't care now and so
now you have this subscriber that's
never clicking on your videos because
their life changed
and so we have to understand this idea
of what's actually called in business
disappearing customers there's other
names for it customer attrition customer
churn customer turnover customer
cancellation and customer defection it's
all the same idea and i think that if we
wrap our head around that it's like okay
there's gonna be a percentage of my
audience always that's sort of leaving
the back door there's to be a percentage
of my subscribers always that's going
from active to inactive i want to do my
best to keep people engaged but i can't
take full responsibility for that it's
just going to be a fact of life now
listen to this
the average american company
will lose 23
to 30 percent of its customers each year
due to a lack of customer
loyalty
so
don't get this out of context uh context
this is not a youtube stat
but i think it's a metric that we could
correlate to say this that literally
like that here's what i would tell the
think media team
every year
we're gonna lose 30 percent
of our subscribers or people that want
to be a part of even our deeper programs
just because people are moving on
they're doing something else
so if we have a thousand subscribers
every year 300 of our current
subscribers
probably it's probably a good metric it
could be lower it could be higher
depends on the niche but ultimately are
are becoming disengaged out of no fault
of our own right they find somebody else
to follow whatever it is
therefore
you have to have a commitment
to reaching new subscribers
you have to have a commitment to
reaching new viewers and of course we
cover how to do how do you get views how
do you get subscribers we cover that
here on the podcast and in so many other
areas and think media that's our mission
is to help you grow
your youtube channel and you know around
that a business that's profitable and
sustainable and so consider not worrying
too much necessarily about man my
current subscribers but also always
having kind of a one-two punch of
thinking all right it also needs to be
about new new growth new expansion what
video ideas what topics which
net what next innovative campaign could
i lean into to reach new people as we
land the plane
a couple questions for you what topics
would interest the largest percent
of your current subscribers
like what topics would reach the largest
percent of your current subscribers as
opposed to something niche that only
might hit a few of them that's gonna
help you activate your subscribers
second question keep getting one percent
better at click-through rate and average
view duration that's an art form it's an
evolve it's kind of a moving target keep
getting better titles thumbnails content
and make sure you stay linked with us
here at think media we're here to help
and then the last question
what video could you make to attract new
subscribers do you have any ideas if you
didn't just think about reaching here's
here's what my fans my viewers my
audience wants from me what if you think
wider than that
and if you think about expansion what's
the next innovative video idea that
could actually help you grow your
channel and actually think about this
reach fresh subscribers because your
most recent subscriber is probably your
most engaged subscriber they just found
you they're hungry they want more
content the future is forward don't
always be looking backwards in terms of
like how do i reactivate those and i've
evolved my brand so much over the years
if they just click subscribe they're
subscribing in the now they're
subscribing for what's freshly happening
in your brand and your channel now so
lean into that with your next innovative
video idea
wow that episode was fire and i hope you
got your next step so my question to you
is what is your next step what do you
need to do right now if you have dead
subscribers or you want to reach your
active subscribers i want to thank the
two people from the think media
community who submitted that question
and say if you would like to be featured
on the show all you have to do is just
answer a question on our community tab
on twitter or on our instagram that's
right we are asking questions over on
instagram and you can find us at
official think media all right well this
episode is also brought to you by our
think master class we have so many new
listeners and so many people that don't
actually know that we have a deeper
training that is actually not on youtube
it's about youtube but you can't find it
on youtube you have to go to
thinkmasterclass.com
and you'll get a free one-hour class
from sean cannell where he dives into
the three secrets of youtube success
that's right you'll want to make sure
you go there take an hour and watch that
free class and at the end of that class
we give you an opportunity to join us
deeper in one of our programs well my
name is heather torres and thank you so
much for listening to today's episode
and we'll catch you on the next one bye